hi there steve coffin here
listen i would like some advice some
help
uh about travel to australia new zealand
my wife
has a very good friend from high school
and she lives in australia and her
daughter is getting married and so now
we're going down there
to be there at the wedding
and it looks like we're going to leave
vancouver around the end of february
and i'm thinking of stopping off
we can get a real good deal on air new
zealand seems to be the cheapest waiting
for us to get down there
stop in uh
the cook islands
then new zealand north island of new
zealand we're going flying into auckland
then uh
this friend of my wife's lives in
brisbane but the wedding is in sydney
so we were thinking of maybe spending
say two three days in the cook islands
cook's tour two three days in the cook
islands maybe
a week
the north island of new zealand
then fly to brisbane
and then
do whatever touring we should be doing
in australia for
maybe two weeks
included of course in that will be a
trip to uh sydney to be at the wedding
uh but we'll spend some time with uh
my wife's friend in brisbane
my question is
where should i go
what should i do or what should we do uh
a week in the north island what can we
do we are bringing our golf clubs we do
like to golf
we don't like to stay in fancy resorts
but we don't want to be
in cockroach infested um
you know
fleabag type places either
um i would appreciate any advice on
travel cook islands
new zealand
australia
uh i hope that uh someone out there
either lives there or has been to those
places we're looking forward to our trip
but i also look forward to hearing from
you thank you
a new way of using the internet to
find out about where to go and where to
stay thanks bye